luke and nate here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel we're here in the
alaskan bush
camping in a blizzard with no tent yeah
[Music]
it's a cold winter morning here in
alaska
the sun's been up for 30 minutes which
means it's only 11 a.m
we've got about four and a half hours of
sunlight left
so we gotta find a spot to camp build a
shelter
get a fire all that good stuff in a very
quick
amount of time
oh there's a lot of rabbit tracks around
here look at that
big old fat snowshoe hair
all right nate what do you think about
this spot
okay
there you go you've got snow shoes bud
i have no idea how deep the snow is we
got some depth
[Music]
well that's pretty deep
you're tall as i am
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
all right i think i need to cut some
stairs in this
[Music]
every time you dig one of these things
you never really know what's gonna be
under the snow you could have big stumps
or rocks or you know who knows what
luckily we just got a few willow bushes
so we're gonna get those out of the way
let's get you a little snack uh-huh does
that look good
you having fun yeah good so you can see
here
i'm making kind of an s shape to this
trench
and i'm doing that to keep the wind from
blowing straight down the trench
i now i just need to put a roof on it so
if we get a big dump of snow tonight
we don't wake up under a foot of snow
let's go find some wood
not a lot of standing dead wood around
here and anything on the ground
is buried so man we're gonna have
trouble finding
finding wood
i'm just not seeing any standing dead
wood there's a big moose prince see
that's the big moose
there's a fox and there's rabbit print
man it's a beautiful area yeah a little
dead
dead spruce right there
oh you'll see if this fits
oh not by much but it fits
[Music]
oh
i hope i built this roof sturdy enough
because if we get a foot or two of snow
it's gonna get
really heavy but we've got a lot of
cross members to try to distribute the
weight and
we'll see what happens
ugh
a lot of these self-inflating mattresses
don't work as well in the cold
the plastic gets too stiff this one
doesn't want to do anything
oh yeah there we go
luckily it's not so big
there you go you take your your boots
off
we're gonna put on your your camp boots
these will keep your feet warm
without getting your bag dirty but just
don't walk on the snow in these okay
i gotta blanky time okay
i gotta get some firewood cut up
oh boy that's a pretty small pile of
firewood just wasn't able to find much
in the way of dead falls here
i really want to have a fire right as i
go to bed tonight and in the morning
when we wake up
so i'm going to cook with my stove just
kind of save our firewood
look at this nathan's already fast
asleep
but i'm gonna get him some food before i
wake him up
got some reindeer sausage here
[Music]
the normal backpacking stoves you see a
lot run off of pressurized isobutane but
it doesn't work in cold temperatures
so i'm using uh white gas liquid
white gas but this stuff's actually kind
of cool this stove will run off of
diesel kerosene
white gas you know so you got a lot of
different options
nathan buddy wake up we got dinner
hey then they didn't even eat dude we
got dinner
there we go some reindeer sausage curry
does that taste good bud yeah nice and
warm food
oh my goodness this smells so good
that reindeer tikka masala curry oh that
warms me up it's probably just because
i'm so cold and hungry but this is the
best tasting curry i've ever had
it is rough starting a fire when
everything's covered in ice and snow
it's worse than
trying to start a fire in a pouring
rainstorm
all right time to do the dishes
if you watch my shows you know i swear
by these 12-hour
adhesive body warmers they are great
for keeping kids warm in their sleeping
bag
go ahead and hop in bed
how's that nathan you warm well this is
nathan's first time using his brand new
winter sleeping bag
and it's a really nice bag it's
very hard to find good kids bags but
feathered friends which makes some of
the best down sleeping bags on the
market
they will customize the lengths for you
so i got him one of the
the women's bags which are narrower than
the men's bags
and i just had him shorten it a bunch so
this is about a five foot
four inch uh sleeping bag and he's
about four feet tall so he's got plenty
of room to grow into it
you like that nathan
[Music]
the boy just bros in there like a tick
we're gonna put nathan's boots
and his uh coat up here so it doesn't
get snowed on
i'm gonna do the same thing with my coat
that's gonna be my pillow tonight
hey nathan you want me to put your
blankie in your sleeping bag
well it's nine o'clock so the sun has
been down for five and a half hours
already
but uh i think i am going to get ready
for bed and hop in my sleeping bag
maybe watch a movie or something just
kind of take it easy i'm kind of envying
nathan they'll cuddle up
right there i don't have as much room as
nathan so i'm going to put my boots
under my mat like that to keep the snow
out of them
you know these big fluffy sleeping bags
are great insulators
but they have one weakness the part of
the bag that's underneath you
is squished by your body weight and when
your bag is squished
it doesn't insulate heat very well so
that's why
it's really important to have a good mat
to make up
for that lack of insulation underneath
you and uh
i've got this mundo king therm-a-rest
and it's just kind of the best in the
business this thing is such a great
great insulator
[Music]
well guys i have slept better tonight
than i have in a long
time we slept ten and a half hours
it's almost nine o'clock right now and
the sun's still not
up well we got a bit of a storm last
night we had this howling wind coming
through the valley
you could hear it just roaring through
the trees but we're in a real
sheltered spot so only occasionally a
gust would
rock the shelter but the wind didn't get
in at all so it's
nice and toasty in here
oh yeah we got some snow up there
i think there's a bit of snow on our
roof hey nate you cozy
yes good two thumbs up
awesome beaver i mean shoe ball oh
i don't want to get out of my sleeping
bag when i was a kid our youth group
from church used to go winter camping
all the time and one
time we'd made a whole bunch of snow
caves and everyone was all tucked in
their snow caves and a big old moose
came walking through
and stepped through the roof of one of
the kids snow caves and the hoof
came through right next to his head
and he's with started screaming and the
moose freaked out and it started
dancing and ran off and trampled his
snow cave and
luckily didn't step on the kid but he he
was sitting there in a pile of snow
going oh oh
gosh i don't think we'll have any moose
stepping on us today
all right i'm doing it definitely got
some snow last night
all the firewood's covered in snow yay
all right
man you can really hear the wind now the
snow
insulates the sound so much just
couldn't hear how loud it was
it's really roaring out here man the
snow is still coming down
pretty good i don't want to get all wet
i think i'm just going to bust the stove
out and cook under the
awning
i got a muffin here you want to eat a
muffin
little trick for melting snow you got to
put a little water in the bottom of the
pan or you'll melt your pot
there it doesn't take much but
oh mekong oranges my absolute favorite
fruit in the world
ready for some hot chocolate you want
your egg first okay
[Music]
[Music]
i've got some brownie mix inside this
mug we're gonna make steamed brownies
the brownies are almost done so we're
gonna get some ice cream to go with our
brownies
just take some of the fluffy new snow
here just a little dab
of vanilla and sweetened condensed milk
and it should be cold you don't want to
melt your snow
if it's really cold and dry snow it
works a little better this is kind of
wet stuff
there we go vanilla ice cream
that tastes good tastes like real ice
cream
my fingers are so cold i can grab it
right out of the boiling water
there we go steamed brownie when you
steam a brownie it comes out just like
it was baked
only it's more moist it's really nice
you know what this brownie needs some
ice cream
oh you don't want any of this nathan it
doesn't taste very good
you like that i got i got a more
reindeer sausage that's that's my
breakfast
i'm really glad we picked this spot
these trees
are taking the brunt of this wind
man you can hear it just howling over
there apparently last night around 1 am
there was 90 mile per hour winds
and it's been pumping between 20 to 30
mile per hour winds
just a few hundred yards up the side of
the valley
it's been really nasty but we're down
here in this little gully and it's just
every once in a while we get a crazy
gust of wind comes ripping through
but you can go and you can see the trees
up on the side of the mountain are just
ripping and moving back and forth so
becca's been texting me
trying to make sure that we're okay and
luckily i've got this little garmin
inreach mini so i've been able to text
her back and say no no we're fine we're
fine yeah
and it's really nice being underneath
the snow you just can't hear anything
and the wind just doesn't affect you at
all
i gotta get you dressed it's gonna be
cold
all right all right nathan should we
pack it up and snowshoe out of here yeah
all right let's do it
it's sad to tear it down it's been a
great shelter but i need my tarp back
you okay back there
oh nathan i'm tired how about you
well hopefully you guys enjoyed this
video if you want to see more extreme
camping videos and winter survival
videos
check out our camping video playlist and
don't forget to click
subscribe to the outdoor boys youtube
channel for new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching
nailed it let's go inside
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching